une bonne impression de cette audience
nous les croiser ip en général on a une
bonne impression
je porte ce faisant je peux pas dire
plus que ce qu'il a été dit je crois que
tout a été dit cette histoire oui bien
si on va pour résumer vous avez un
accident de voiture
vous avez dérapé sur du sable mouillé un
témoin s'en est mêlée ça le regarde et
nous allons regarder pas il vous a
injurié et mon dieu
leila comme on dit une empoignade soit
une accolade on avait l'impression que
l'avion brasse et une empoignade à kolin
alors on attend demain ça me fend
d'amande pour johnny hallyday 500 francs
pour le conducteur pour coup 500 francs
pour injure c'est le genre d'accolades
il finit par coûter très cher